Speaker 1: We have news in terms of the debt
ceiling.
I'm going to give you the news, but I'm also
going to tell you why I really haven't been
covering the debt ceiling story that much.
And I know that there's some in the audience
who agree with my reasoning, and there's some
in the audience who who don't.
So to begin with, the House is going to vote
to extend the debt ceiling through early December.
CNN reporting on this The House of Representatives
expected to vote today to extend the debt
limit through early December after the Senate
approved a stopgap measure last week in a
bid to avert a catastrophic default and economic
disaster.
Once the Democratic controlled House passes
the short term extension, it will be cleared
for President Joe Biden's signature.
Janet Yellen, the Treasury secretary, warned
lawmakers the federal government will likely
run out of cash by October 18 unless Congress
raises the debt ceiling, setting up a ticking
clock and high stakes.
Congress may not even have that long to act,
since the deadline is more of a best guess
estimate than a set in stone deadline.
That dynamic intensified pressure on Democrats
and Republicans to reach a deal to address
the debt limit.
OK, so what we're talking about here
Speaker 2: is
Speaker 1: passing a debt limit increase to
enable the Treasury to keep borrowing money
to pay bills for two months.
This would be temporary.
This will set up another round of the exact
same thing in December.
So why haven't I been talking about this that
much?
Quite frankly, and I want to be careful with
my language.
You as an individual should barely care about
this.
The debt ceiling was created in the first
place to put a limit on how much debt the
government could take on without requiring
a really clumsy process that was in place
beforehand.
We don't even need to go over the process
that was in place beforehand.
The point was just let them take on debt,
but cap it so they can't go beyond a certain
amount without coming back to us.
It's sort of like, actually, he'll.
Bloom has a good Twitter thread on this and
say, he'll tweeted, This is sort of like it
used to be that you had to get approval every
time you wanted to buy something on your credit
card.
Now it's you just have a spending limit in
total on the credit card and you can buy whatever
you want until you hit that limit.
If you hit the limit, you got to ask for an
increase.
Every once in a while, you're going to need
to raise it.
Why?
Well, the country keeps growing, the economy
keeps growing.
And so even if you maintain the same percentage
of the economy and debt, the raw numbers are
going to go up over time.
But this entire process was basically a rubber
stamp.
We've got to raise it.
We're a growing country.
Our economy grows.
We've got to raise the debt ceiling.
Debt ceiling increases, remember, are needed
for prior spending that's already been authorized.
Republicans like to play this game where they
say, we're not going to do this and allow
Democrats to keep spending us into debt oblivion.
Hold on.
That's grandstanding.
That's a lie it.
They want to pretend that this is to stop
Democrats from spending.
It's for prior spending that was already approved
by Congress.
The fear is, if they don't do this, the U.S.
will default on its debt so that all the fear
mongering and the headline start.
And Republicans say we're going to default
because we have too much debt and Democrats
won't stop spending.
The reality is we default if Republicans don't
raise the debt ceiling, which is supposed
to be merely perfunctory.
Some Republicans will say that's the problem.
It can't be perfunctory that we go into more
and more and more debt.
But the time to talk about that is when you
authorize the spending that now simply needs
to be paid for.
And what we end up doing is giving oxygen
to something where nobody really benefits
from there.
Being more stories about the debt ceiling,
we're actually giving them attention, which
makes them more eager not to just raise the
debt ceiling.
And let's continue.
So they're going to get this solved for two
months.
It'll come up again in December.
It'll get solved again, and it's in no one's
interest to actually not raise the debt ceiling
over the long term.
And if people didn't ignorantly react to it,
it would get less oxygen oxygen to begin with,
and it would deflate this as something that
Republicans want to get attention for.
Think about the number of interviews over
the last, you know, weeks, months, however
long all about this and in the interviews,
they're not even mentioning the fundamental
point, which is.
We are now Republicans.
We are now trying not to raise the debt ceiling
to pay for spending we already approved.
We already approved the spending.
It's not for new spending, it's not for Joe
Biden's new proposals, it's just not what
it's for.
So the reason I haven't been covering it is
this really shouldn't be a thing in that this
is just a perfunctory part of running government.
You want to run government a different way
where this doesn't come up.
We could talk about that.
You want to have a bigger conversation about
debt and deficit.
We can do that.
But this is for already approved spending.
You can't now say, Well, we approved it, but
we're not going to cut the check, so to speak,
or allow the spending to happen to cover,
allow the debt ceiling to increase, to cover
the spending.
That's why I haven't been covering it.
I don't think any of us really benefit from
talking endlessly about this.
If you disagree with me.
Let me know by next Tuesday, one week from
today, six p.m. Eastern will be having the
David Pakman show live town hall.
It will be streaming on one place, only The
David Pakman Show second YouTube channel.
That's Packman Live YouTube.com slash Pacman
Live will be opening the phone lines.
Members will get priority, but it'll be open
to everyone.
You can sign up at Join Packman dot com.
Subscribe free to the YouTube channel youtube.com
slash Pacman Live and will be live next Tuesday
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
I hope to see you there.
Remember that the David Pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you through
our membership program, you can grab a membership
at join Packman dot com, whether you watch
on YouTube or listen to the podcast, by the
way.
Audio podcast record week last week for the
year, more people listen to the audio podcast
last week than in any week, dating all the
way back to the week after the election November
of 2021.
Things were crazy.
We haven't even been promoting the audio podcast,
but it is.
It's going nuts.
So thanks to everybody who's been listening
and you can sign up at Join Packman dot com.
You get a bunch of great perks, including
the Daily Bonus Show just for our members.